so I've been digging through all these
NSA documents that were leaked to the
public and they are full of some amazing
graphic design look at this so we're
looking at top secret like NSA spy
documents and we're also looking at how
they use Windows 95 Microsoft Word
templates to Brand all of their big spy
efforts like yes this is a plan to
collect a bunch of people's personal
data and sift through it to spy on the
American people but we gotta use the
clip art to make sure that it's pretty
this is one of my personal favorites
just look at that graphic design like
some NSA employees like we can't hire
graphic designers because we are like
working on top secret but uh we got
Windows 95 here's a favorite Mystic
it is wild to me how easy it is to
romanticize government spies but when
you see the real thing it's a lot
clunkier and a lot less sexy than in the
movies